[Music]
reinvention my industry means
challenging assumptions so in our case
nobody when we started nobody thought
that this sort of direct-to-consumer
super kind of transactional experience
would make sense like a lot of the stuff
in the social media a lot of stuff in
the influencer celebrity space is either
a driven it's one-to-many so this kind
of one-to-one relationship was kind of a
disruptive business model at the time so
I think reinvention tends to look a lot
like that these days
[Music]
right now the way that people interact
with celebrities online is typically
super one-sided so like you might watch
all of a youtubers YouTube videos over
the course of years you feel like you're
best friends with them but you've never
met them you have no way of contacting
them if you comment on their tweets or
on their instagrams like they're not
gonna see it they're not gonna reply and
so cameo is the first time that
somebody's been able to make it a
two-sided conversation I was at
Microsoft working on the Windows user
experience team and I had a friend who
was in Silicon Valley he was working at
a start-up in Silicon Valley and we both
put our jobs and we traveled for a year
we built a bunch of apps and websites
and we've got super popular and vine and
then we came back to America we came
back to LA he pursued being a youtuber
full time and I was doing a lot of
freelance work and trying to figure out
what I want to do next and and Steven
came to me with cameos and I had a bunch
of fans from vine and literally my dams
were filled with people who were like my
sister is such a huge fan of you could
you send her a happy birthday message or
send her a shout-out it would mean the
world to her so I was like I literally
have fans in my DMS that are asking for
this and so that's kind of what we
started with and right off the bat it's
been we had like a super positive
reception
a challenge that was kind of unexpected
was building a team you talk to
investors and you talk to your customers
and everybody's ten under ten excited
about this and it's still hard to build
and grow an awesome team it kind of
sounds obvious and when I say it but in
the moment it's like why does everybody
not want to work here like this should
be the easiest thing in the world
everybody should be inbound
but competitions pretty real in terms of
how the industry will shift in the next
five years one thing I think we'll see
is a lot of disruption when it comes to
what companies look like I think is
gonna be kind of like in the
entertainment industry where there's
like always new and videos and
everything's changing all the time I
think we're gonna see a lot more of that
where things are kind of popping up and
dying and changing and dwarfing a lot
more consistently and faster in that in
the coming years
[Music]
you